Harvard and he's gonna be talking about
the filling arguments and so I was told
that since I'm the last talk of the day
I can pretty much go as long as I want
so we're gonna have like a ted cruz type
event going on here for they'll try to
try to be more or less on time so this
talk was gonna be sort of meant for a
broad audience so for those of you who
know all this stuff i'm gonna apologize
in advance but i'm gonna do sort of a
survey of peeling arguments and where
they come from and some of the places
they arise then i'll talk about you know
some of my own work and then i'll have a
few slides at the end that at least
provides some you know details of what
some of the new stuff is even if i'm not
going to present the full arguments okay
so let's start with one of the very
basic peeling arguments so we have a
graph and we'd like to find a matching
usually this is in the context of a
random graph and so what can you do well
you can use the following sort of
peeling approach i'm going to find a
vertex of degree 1 okay so there's just
one edge out of it so i might as well
throw it into the matching with you the
other vertex on the other edge and
repeat and you can prove pretty easily
that this is sort of an optimal strategy
in the sense they you know as long as
you do this there's a maximal matching
where those edges are involved in the
matching okay and so you can just repeat
this process until you're out of
vertices of degree 1 and then you quit
right so just we're all on the same page
right there's an edge of degree 1 so i'm
gonna throw it in the matching and i'm
gonna peel it away and once i peel away
those two vertices right that that's in
the matching all the roommate
corresponding edges right all the other
adjacent edges adjacent to the other
vertex are also going to disappear great
and what that means is that you can see
is that even though I only started here
with one vertex of degree one because
I'm sort of removing edges as I peel
things lo and behold another vertex of
degree one is now freed up so I can
continue peeling and so on and I can
sort of match everything so that's how
peeling sort of works
and this algorithm for matching in a
random graph was studied by a couple of
no names carps and sip sir way back when
and they showed that there's a threshold
behavior and this is sort of very common
when you look at peeling arguments in
the setting of random graphs that you
get a sort of threshold behavior where
things have below the threshold happen
one way with high probability and above
the threshold happened another way with
high probability and the threshold
behavior was that they showed that if
the number of edges is sufficiently
small you know if you have a sparse
enough graph if it's less than en over 2
then this process will continue until
it's left with a vanishingly small
number of edges right so by doing this
process you're getting up to low order
terms the maximum matching and I should
point out that above the threshold in
fact you know sort of the opposite
happens that you get some sort of linear
size clump leftover of edges okay and
they used an analysis based on of all
things differential equations and I'm
not going to try and put up differential
equations although maybe this audience
is more familiar there's more applied
math type people and this audience might
actually that differential equations but
differential equations is sort of a way
of analyzing the limiting performance of
these types of systems let's look at
another example that more complicated a
satisfiability peeling argument so here
we're talking about random KSAT right
here's example 3sat right so each Clause
has three variables in it we choose them
and they're sign whether they're negated
or not randomly and that's how we get a
random case that formula and we can look
at the ratio of the number of clauses to
the number of variables right I can have
M variables and I can consider how many
clauses I have and of course the the
cave get in this example is 3 is how
many literals per clause and so there's
something called the pure literal rule
okay and the pure literal is while you
have a pure literal that is you know
while you have a literal that appears
only positively or only neg
right so that's why it says appear zero
times maybe it appears zero times
positively or zero times negatively okay
so while you have a literal that appears
zero times you can set its value to zero
and it's negation to one right it's only
appearing one way in the clause set it
the way that you know it's true in all
the clauses that it's in okay and once
that's done we can again peel away that
variable peel away all the clauses that
it's involved in because those are now
satisfied and continue you can view this
as again you can stick it in a random
graph interpretation by viewing it as a
bipartite graph with vertices being
literals on one side and clauses on the
other and the point is is that when you
get to something that sort of has a
degree 0 right you can think of these
literals as being in positive negative
pairs and when one of them drops to 0
you get to remove them in the
neighboring clauses so it's a slightly
more complicated way of graph that you
might be thinking of you've got pairs of
things to worry about instead of
individual things and so on you've got
counts but you can still put it into
this sort of random graph framework and
this was first studied by Berto freeze
and up fall in 1996 and then I like look
at the carps observed paper sort of
figured out you could also put it in a
differential equation form to get sort
of these constants in in tight form and
again you have this sort of threshold
behavior that when the ratio of the
number of clauses to the number of
variables is below some constant then
the pure literal world pure literal
algorithm will find a solution with high
probability and above it won't love it
we'll get to some sort of clumping step
alright so one of the hopes of this talk
is to sort of convince you that this is
not just sort of a random accident this
is actually like an algorithmic paradigm
right so much as we have dynamic
programming and greedy algorithms and
divide and conquer I like to think of
have people be aware of or think of the
peeling paradigm in terms of algorithms
it's really I guess a subclass of
style algorithms right it's a greedy
approach but it's one that comes up
enough that I think it should have you
know its own you know mental framework
and way of people thinking about it and
again the general approach of this is
you find a node of degree one remove all
the edges and the other adjacent node
and continue but as we've seen already
there are sort of variations on the
theme one of the most common variations
is that you might not really need the
node to have degree one you might be
okay is that as long as its degree is at
most some number right and so
combinatorial lists or graph theorist
will know this is called the cake or
it's the maximal sub graph with all the
degrees of the vertices being at least k
the cake or is unique and you can find
the cake or by peeling right so if you
continuously find vertices with degree
you know less than k remove them in this
peeling sort of way what you will be
left with is in fact the cake or okay
you can get in simple inductive type
proof okay
and you know one of the ways that it
comes out in the analysis is as you peel
you know that makes it useful the reason
that these sorts of analyses work is
that if you start with a random graph
generally what you can show is that
inductively you still have a random
graph as you peel you know so in every
step in the way you can say oh i still
have a random graph it's just the degree
distribution is going to change as you
go right because the degree distribution
may depend on you know what things
you've already now deleted in particular
it affects how many edges are left for
so on for example all right so the first
two examples I gave may seem like pretty
theoretical problems and the point is
you know these are not just for theory
therefore you know more practical theory
sort of thing like codes error
correcting ratio correcting codes and
hash-based data structures and one of
the things I've been finding in my work
is these ideas somehow just keep popping
up over and over again which is great
for me because I get to keep writing the
same paper but finally
a different application but in terms of
like this practice theory connection is
that the resulting algorithms data
structures are tend to be really very
efficient very fast and that makes sense
right there following greedy algorithm
approach one of the things we we I teach
my undergrads and that algorithms class
is that you know greedy is the first
thing you should try because when it
works it's amazingly fast and simple and
works really well okay and because of
this I think you know the peeling
paradigm I suspect we're going to find a
lot more places where it's going to be
useful for Big Data algorithms because
if you're focusing on Big Data you
really need things to work fast you
really want to be thinking in terms of
linear time algorithms you may be
willing to give up other things in order
to get linear time and because these are
simple greedy algorithms they tend to
work in linear time so let me give just
another couple of quick examples
peeling algorithms came up a lot and
from my work on low-density parity-check
codes the way to think of low-density
parity-check codes as you have sort of
the messages symbols that you want to
send on the left and you have some
amount of redundancy that you're also
going to send with it on the right which
is generally going to be the exclusive
or of some of the original message
symbols okay and you can think of this
again naturally as a graph right where
you're connected to the things that are
being x ORD worked on a bunch of
low-density parity-check codes where
that graph in the middle was random
according to some degree distribution
right and the basic algorithms that work
are by peeling right so this is decoding
by peeling so here if the colors are
working for you the blue dots or maybe
things that have arrived successfully
and the reddish type things with the
question marks or things that haven't
right and you can see right this first
dot up at the top was the exclusive-or
of a B and F but if you have a and F
arrived right then you can you know
solve linear equations and unknowns you
can exclusive-or those values back in
and you say hey look what's left in that
node there is the value B which I
happened
have been missing right so I can recover
the value of B and I can once I've
recovered the value of B I'm going to
remove that node and the adjacent edges
from the graph what I mean by removing
that node in the adjacent edges from the
graph as I go ahead and exclusive-or
that value back into the neighbors and
try and keep going right you can see
again I have the same process here where
I've now discovered or developed a new
node that just has a single value in
which lets me recover another value and
so on so a lot of the low-density
parity-check code algorithms the fast
ones are based on peeling right so
successful decoding here means emptying
out the graph right or equivalently
saying that the graph has an empty two
core okay and so you use the peeling
analysis to determine when you get the
empty two core with high probability and
again you have this threshold effect
that you know you can cracked up to a
certain number of missing symbols and
there's a threshold for that using this
sort of peeling analysis right another
recent place where peelings come up is
work on tabulation hashing which has
been by a Petrescu and thora
so tabulation hashing the ideas that you
actually start with a big table that's
going to give you your hash values right
so the idea is here I've taken say all
eight bit sequences and I have this sort
of character table of which is marked
with four characters and inside the
table I filled with some random strings
okay in this case the random strings are
all 12 bit long 12 bits long and what
this allows me to do is say okay I can
develop a hash value for any 32-bit
string into a 12 bit string using this
table by just exhorting these random
values together okay so if this say was
my 32-bit string right which we can see
breaks up into four characters each of
eight bits
okay so for the first character I look
up the corresponding entry in the
character one column the second eight
bits and the character two column and so
on and I get these four twelve bit
values and I just XOR them together and
that will be my hash value all right and
now what does this have to do with
peeling so if I have a set of strings
being hash I can peel as follows okay so
if I can find a string in that set where
it's the only string that maps to a
specific character value position right
so if there's only one string that say
lands in that you know green spot right
there that I've marked okay then that
strings hash value is going to be
independent of all the other strings in
the set because it's been X Ord with its
own unique independent random value so
what I can do is now peel that string
out of the set and continue okay and
maybe this opens up a new degree one
cell in the table for some other string
which will itself I'll then be able to
say has its own unique independent value
and so on okay so you can view the
question of does this set of strings are
they all getting independent values you
can view that in terms of the spilling
process and using that idea patrasche go
and throw thora prove you know some
interesting things about these sorts of
hashing which I'm just not even gonna
get into cuz I have you know more slides
than I have time and I really don't want
to keep you here all day okay so that's
sort of a survey of a bunch of old stuff
let me now try and you know present some
some more newest stuff okay and so I'll
talk a bit about invertible bloom
look-up tables which are sort of I'm not
sure if I want to call me extension or
sort of a tighter analysis of some of
the work on invertible bloom filters so
really all this is Michael goodrich's
work who's going to be talking tomorrow
okay so let me tell you before I get
into the data structure let me tell you
about the problems that the data
structure is designed to help solve so
when it's called the stragglers problem
okay so we can think of it you know in
in networking we'd think of it as flows
going through a router in other
applications we might just think of it
in security applications we might think
of it as people entering and leaving a
building right so people enter their
building over time at the end of a
people leave a building you'd like to
make sure that everybody's left or
possibly recover the people who are or
you know who are left now this is easy
to do right you can just keep a very
very big list of all the people that
have entered the building but from a
data structure point of view this seems
very wasteful you're keeping a long list
when at the end of the day the
information that you're going to want is
this very small number of people who
might still be left in the building
right so if you have some bound say on
that number what you'd like is some sort
of structure that's proportional to the
size not of the entire list of people
who go in and out right but what you
want is a data structure whose size is
proportional to the the number of people
who are left at the end of the day the
people who you want to list at the end
of the process does that application
make sense all right a similar you can
sort of maybe see the relationships
similar sort of application has to do
asset reconciliation and here we think
of maybe a practical setting as being in
the context of data bases distributed
databases where two parties have nearly
the same data base but maybe they've
gone out of sync for a small period of
time and they want to reconcile
themselves right so a way to model this
is we have two players each with their
own set of keys which we assume have a
very large overlap and we want the
parties to learn the set difference what
are the keys I have you don't have say
and vice versa okay and again the goal
here should be not that we have to send
all the data over right ideally what
we'd like is that the amount of
communication is proportional to the
size of the difference not to the size
of the actual structures themselves
all right so invertible blue and look-up
tables which are sort of a variation
themselves some bloom filters give a way
of doing this alright so i blt data
structures you can say insert key value
pairs delete key value pairs you can get
the value for a key with the possibility
of some sort of error the error being
that you might say you know I'm not sure
what the value is I couldn't find the
value in some instances okay and you'd
also like to be able to list entries so
it will list all the current key value
pairs as long as the load is not too
high that is you have to put in some
sort of design threshold that says I can
list out these key values for you with
high probability as long as the number
of them they say not too high in terms
of the analysis wouldn't do this work
there are various ways settings you
could imagine the analysis so a nicest
system would have the property that each
key would just have one value and you
only delete things that have actually
been inserted right you aren't going to
delete things that aren't already in the
system and there are other versions that
are less nice that might have multiple
key value pairs or duplicates or other
deletions and things for now let's focus
at least on the thinking of it for the
nice system that's what I'll go over
here okay so the nice system is really
going to look like for those of you have
seen it although I'm not gonna describe
it to here sort of a bloom filter okay
so the idea is we take a table we'll
split it up into separate sub tables and
we'll hash each pair J times so we'll
have J sub tables we'll have J hash
functions each hash function will give a
location in one of the sub tables and
will happen is that in each of those
locations we're going to on an insert
will say increase the count for that
cell note that there's one more thing
there will keep a key sum and a value
sum okay
you can think of some as being actual
some or generally what we'll do is just
use X or z-- right so the sum there is
gonna be an X or some nice thing about
using an X or some as than the degree
decrease count is extremely symmetric
delete sort of do the opposite okay all
right now you can see what happens if
you're doing a get operation you know
find me the value you can say well if
there's any cell that has a count of 1
right and the key matches right then
you've found the right key and you can
rationally return the value and in it
may be the case though that even though
the key is in the system other items
have hashed the same locations and so
you can't tell what the key is and in
that case you may have to return not
found I couldn't find you the value of
the key and depending on how you
parameterize the system that'll
determine the probability that you can
successfully return a value for the gap
and and I'm not gonna spend a lot of
time on the details here so I can get
through throw some of the other stuff
but you can use a bloom filter type
analysis to get the probability that
gets returned not found for keys in the
system and for keys not in the system
yeah ok so what about the bay the more
interesting part listing ok so how do
you do listing well it's just going to
be the same peeling process right so
while you can find something that has a
count of 1 pull it out of the system
pull out the key and the value
delete it from the I BLT and keep going
ok so this would be like one sort of
step you could see here right so over
here on the left you know
I've managed to find a cell that has a
count of 1 right so I find the key in
the cell look at all the places that
that hashes to right and I say aha I can
now delete this item so I reduce all
those counts and look lo and behold it's
created a new cell that has just one
thing in it which gives me the next
thing that I can recover and again the
hope is that I can
peeling all the way until I've removed
everything from the table all right so
that's our the verbal description of
this listing process you know while you
find things with a count of one take out
the key value pair call delete and keep
going right and this is exactly the same
peeling process that we've seen before
to find you know when you talked about
for decoding it corresponds to finding
the two core of a random hypergraph and
complete recovery means that you end up
with an empty two core that is you've
peeled away the entire graph so we can
use results for these sort of thresholds
to say when we can recover or exactly
what that means it's like how much space
we need to store n items right it
depends on the number of hash functions
right so you know M over N the ratio of
space we need we need like if we want to
be able to recover from n items inside
when we use three hash functions we need
about one point two n cells right so the
space factor that we need is a small
constant additional factor it increases
with the number of hash functions but
the probability of success increases
with the number of hash functions so
they're sort of a trade-off there I
usually think at least for these data
structures as being regular but if you
wanted to push the 1.22 down to you know
1 plus epsilon ish there are ways to do
that by using what are called you know
corresponding to irregular codes there
are irregular AI BLTs where different
keys end up having different number of
hash functions turns out that that's a
useful way to drive the space cost down
okay so our gain near the end of my time
across just a couple more minutes I'm
just gonna give some of the applications
and recent results for AI BLTs and and
for peeling so one thing that we've done
is you know it's sort of funny that I
described low-density parity-check codes
and the peeling process and then I
described I BLTs perhaps maybe not so
surprisingly you can turn around and
say well if you've got the IB LT is sort
of your base data structure you can turn
around and build just build a code
naturally on top of that and that was
worth work with George Varghese you know
you don't need to think about graphs you
can just think about hashing this may
not be you know it doesn't give you a
sense any new coding results but I
personally think that if I was gonna
introduce coding say to undergraduate
algorithms course I would prefer to
under gret prefer to introduce it by way
of hashing than by way of say random
graphs or other things so you know
didactically I think this is a pretty
interesting way of getting students to
interested in coding right so this just
gives you a variant on these low-density
parity-check codes for correcting errors
on what's called the QR channel where
the qre channel means that your symbols
are actually you can think of those
strings as bits is you can think of
working from you know mod Q it's all
done in terms of hashing and makes use
of this sort of connection between set
reconciliation and coding and so here
I'm really just I'm not going to get
into how you build the Biff code you
know you can look at the paper if you
want to see that but just sort of state
the result all right some newer stuff
out on the archive which I guess you
know fits into the theme of go I wanted
at least a few slides to explain why I
was invited here so talk about parallel
peeling all right so the idea of
parallel peeling right is that you know
think you've got this random graph or
random hyper graph and what I've been
saying is that while there's a node that
has degree less than K it can remove
itself from the graph and the adjacent
edges and continue and I've been
describing that as a sequential process
right but there's no reason you couldn't
turn that into a parallel process right
if you have a thread say for each vertex
right the vertices can you know each
individually look at themselves say hey
wait you know I've got too few edges I'm
going to remove myself from the graph
okay and that can all happen in pair
at the same time for many notes so sort
of the first high level question you'd
ask is how many of these rounds of
peeling are necessary if the nodes are
doing this in parallel okay and it turns
out that there's something really you
know to me it was a bit surprising and
interesting what happened which is that
if you're above the threshold that is if
you're collapsing to a non-trivial core
a non-empty non-trivial core then it
actually took at least yo Omega log n
rounds to complete on the other hand if
you're below the threshold that is
you're going to an empty core then it
actually only took or only order log log
n rounds okay and to me what's fun or
exciting as a theorist about this result
is that almost all the applications that
I know and care about for peeling the
goal is to get an empty core right this
sort of complete recovery in the IB LT
or complete decoding there so on the
goal is to get an empty core so I find
it to sort of nice that you know nature
made it the case that the setting that I
want algorithmically is the faster case
you know theoretically so because of
this peeling algorithms are fast and
very Amina bowl to parallelization I'll
just sort of briefly spend a minute
sketching the argument you know the this
typically follows a typical way of
analyzing these sorts of things is to
start with a random tree argument random
hypergraphs sparse random hypergraphs
locally look like a tree and if you just
think of them as being a tree just
ignore the fact that you know things may
collide you can develop a recursion for
the fraction of Peel nodes after J
rounds based on what happened after J
minus 1 rounds by carefully examining
the tree and what ends up happening for
those who know about my work on on load
balancing and how you know where log log
ends come in there from double
exponential fall off on the tails you
get actually the same sort of thing out
of these recursions it's actually eerie
how similar in some sense the recursions
come out being you get a double
exponential fall the the probability
that you're still around falls off
double exponentially with the number of
rounds which means you can get order log
log and rounds to finish everything up
you know then once you have this ideal
argument you have to tune it up to deal
with you know annoying probability
issues you know concentration and so on
we can even find the dependence on the
number of rounds required on the gap
from the threshold right as you might
imagine sort of the the closer you are
to the threshold the more rounds it ends
up taking we even implemented this where
obviously by we I mean mostly my student
Justin Taylor or X student Justin Taylor
who is here this year and is in the
audience
besides the theory he actually got
something this going where each cell
gets a thread so we have actual numbers
showing that it works and it was
actually interesting something that came
out of the implementation was we had to
you know sort of go back to the theory
you know a problem is you can think sort
of a locking problem that occurs with
the implementation as what if two nodes
you know want to delete the same edge at
the same time right here so what if you
you have your threads looking at the
vertices and they both say AHA we're
both gonna delete this edge and so they
end up both deleting things at the same
time that would be bad as you try and
continue your I BLT type deletion
process and it turned out this
interesting solution was to use the sub
tables that we we sort of naturally used
in the I BLT the ice the I sub table
comes to sort of the Eifert X in your in
your hyper edge and the idea is that if
you process the sub tables themselves
sequentially within your parallel rounds
you can guarantee that each element is
deleted only once and avoid locking
issues or problems and it turns out that
this is both effective practically and
leads to an interesting analysis
just briefly for the normal analysis
gives a double exponential fall off like
the sort of standard balanced allocation
paradigm this process leads to a
fall-off like voguing x'
variation of the balanced allocation
paradigm for those who know that wear
ties break in one direction there again
all sorts of funny interesting
connections going on here last sort of
bit of new stuff is that something I've
gotten interested in with a variety of
algorithms is that instead of choosing K
random values when you do these sorts of
choosing K random hash function type
tricks suppose instead you use double
hashing okay so the idea in double
hashing is that you pick two values and
just take the natural linear
combinations of them right this is how
double hashing works for normal hash
tables and I'm sort of taking that idea
or the same idea here when I'm saying I
want to choose K hash values okay what
we can show with in some cases in theory
and in other cases just empirically
again this was with Justin was that when
using peeling double hashing is as good
as having K random hashes and there's
some definitely some compelling
intuition for why that's the case in
some cases we can turn that into
intuition into full proofs this is
actually useful in practice the way
people actually implement getting
multiple hash values and practice is
often to use double hashing and so being
able to say that that's perfectly fine
and a good way to do it is it's nice for
making the practitioners happy ok so the
goal here was just to introduce you to
this idea of peeling show you that it
occurs in all sorts of different
settings yields really fast algorithms
very effective Ameena Bowl -
parallelization and so I think it's a
technique that we're going to see keep
arising in a variety of big data type
algorithms going forward
let's thank Michael again